-Welcome back
to "Late Night."
With all of the talk
of financial stimulus,
many Americans
are still wondering
when they'll receive aid
and where all their tax dollars
are going.
Here with more on that is one of
our writers, Jeff Wright.
[ Horn honking ]
[ Bell jingles ]
-Who's next?
-Hey, Government?
-What can I do for you, Citizen?
-I pay my taxes, right?
-You do.
-And it's a lot, right?
-It could be more.
-Well, I've been out of work
for a while now,
and I was wondering
what can I get
for being an active
American citizen?
-The best I can do for you is 6.
-$6,000?
-Hell, no! $600!
-What?! $6,000 wasn't a no.
What you have been doing
with all the money I've been
giving you over the years?
-[ Mumbling ]
-What? Speak up!
-I brought some bombs.
Damn. okay?
-I bought some bombs
to impress some friends.
-You called me?
-Oh, n-not right now, Bomb.
Stay in the back.
I'll let you know what it's lit.
-Alright.
-Look, Citizen.
Best I could do for you
is $600, maybe $2,000.
But I'mma need
at least 20% back.
-Why?
-'Cause I owe some people
some money!
Damn!
-Oy.
-Next!
-Hey, Government.
-Hey, Black Citizen.
-I'd like to trade my
"ancestors were a slave" card.
I was looking to get
40 acres and a mule.
If not a mule,
I'll take a Toyota Camry.
-Y'all still mad
about the slave thing?
Plus, this car is old.
It's not even
in the best condition.
-And whose fault is that?
-Best I could do
is maybe another
black president.
-When?
-I've been dealing
with a headache
for the past four years,
so you got to give me
at least two terms.
-Yeah, alright, but he's got to
be full black this time.
-How about his mom is black
and his dad is Canadian?
Kind of like Drake.
-Man, nobody want Drake
as president.
-It's better than Kanye West.
-You right. Alright, fine.
-Next!
-Hey, Government.
-Hey, Student.
Are you still switching majors?
-Mm-hmm.
-You know, I might have a job
for you when you finish school.
-You lying.
-You right.
What can I do for you?
-Can I speak to Student Loans?
-[ Whispering ] I'm not here.
-He said he's not here
right now.
-I can see him.
-Hey, man,
I was just looking for you.
You got my money?
-No, it's a pandemic.
I'm here to ask
for my money back.
-Whoa, don't say his name
in vain like that.
You in here cussin'.
What money?
-The money I gave you
for school.
It's virtual now,
so I don't see the point
of paying for a school
I technically don't even go to.
-I already spent the money.
-On what?
-An air fryer.
-An air fryer?
-Yeah, you, like, put food in it
and then it, like, heats it up.
-hey, I know
what an air fryer is!
-So you know how cool it is!
-Look, man, why don't you
come back Tuesday?
Maybe I'll see
what I have for you.
-You said that last Tuesday.
-You really gonna help him out?
-[ Scoffs ] No.
[ Laughs ]
-Are you done?
'Cause you still got to
sweep the back.
Your break was over
five minutes ago.
-I don't need this job.
-What?
-Nothing.
-That's what I thought.
And make sure you lock the door.
'Cause how did Black Citizen
get in here?